jack reacher c'est un fantôme a servi
dans la police militaire un brillant
enquêteurs aux fauteurs de trouble si il
ya deux ans il disparaît on trouve pas
ce type s'il ne veut pas excusez moi
monsieur
il ya un certain jack reacher pour vous
appelle vous et b.james bas
vous dites qu'il a abattu cinq personnes
ça je le crois pas mais alors qu'est ce
que vous croyez
il a été piégé qu'est-ce que faire un
flic de l'armée la même chose que vous
avec une légère différence
chaque suspect était entraîné à tuer
qu'est ce qu'on espère trouver la vérité
ce soldat pose des questions que
personne d'autre ne pose trouver
l'avocate hélène je dois expliquer
comment ça marche
tu crois que je suis un héros je suis
pas l'avocat tu et à toi j'ai réfléchi
je crois je préfère te tuer
ils veulent que je m'attire
mais je vais rien lâcher
vous êtes un peu rouillé nourriture
j'ai rien à perdre
et si tu es intelligent tu peux avoir la
trouille
il se fout de la loire
l'isf ou des preuves il ira jusqu'au
bout
sonia